[GAVEL POUNDING]
Welcome back, everyone.
After a very exciting
first session,
I can tell you that the
regents collectively
have expressed a great
deal of excitement
about what they've heard here.
We've had quite a
few looks at this
thanks to President Robbins'
senior team checking in
with us.
So seeing it all come
together and being
presented in the
way it was presented
has really been
rewarding for us.
Many of our questions
were answered
before we got here today.
So don't misread our
lack of questions
as our lack of support or
a lack of true excitement
about what we're seeing.
Quite the contrary.
This group is not shy.
And if we see things that
we have questions about,
President Robbins, you
know you'll hear from us.
I think you can take
the fact that you've
become a student-centered
plan and the exciting new
initiatives that you outlined
are quite exciting for us
as well.
And we support the
pillar one and two.
So, please.
All right.
So we're 15 minutes behind time.
I know I'm focusing on time.
But I want you to be able to
get to where you need to be.
Is today Friday?
I think it is Friday.
Yeah.
Friday, you know, we need
to stop by 1:00 on Friday.
So this third pillar gets us
into our people, our place,
but it's reimagining
the land grant
university in the Fourth
Industrial Revolution.
And we've talked about President
Crow's the New American
University, and
what's our tag line.
I think that it would
be the Land Grant
University in the Fourth
Industrial Revolution,
and to be able to do all the
things that we talked about
in the first two pillars.
This one really focuses on our
service to the state of Arizona
through our land grant mission
to our people, to the place,
to the soul that is
in southern Arizona,
and all of the
connectivity that we have
across all of those assets.
So here are the goals.
We've talked about
earlier on in pillar 1
the graduation and
retention goals.
You'll see that we've called
out our Hispanic Serving
Institution
initiative, our service
to our Native American students.
And then we'll end on
economic development
and how we think that we can
do even better than we're
doing currently, which
is actually much better
than I thought we were doing.
So we'll get there.
So what's the idea around
this new land grant
university for the fourth
Industrial Revolution?
If you go back, we talk
about the moral act
in serving around agriculture
and the mechanical arts,
engineering.
But now, as things are
changing very rapidly,
we need to apply
those new principles
to what it means to be a
new land grant university.
And how we can continue
to foster development
of the entrepreneurial spirit of
this university and the state.
Increase our innovation in
economic development resources
and investment.
And then another point
that I was alluding to
in the first phase was how
can we, as an enterprise,
collaborate across our
three universities?
So this shows one of
the great strengths,
as I was talking
about earlier, is
the enormously diverse makeup
that we have at the university.
Students from every state in
the union and many countries
from around the world.
And I would say that
we have dedicated sites
for each one of these
centers to operate.
But they are
woefully inadequate.
I would like to see
a separate building
for each one of
these interest groups
so that they can have their
own living and learning space,
and they can be more successful.
And I think it's a
competitive advantage for us.
It makes us stronger.
And it will also, investment
in these different diversity
and inclusion
centers will help us
with retention and
graduation rate.
The fact that this last year,
we received the designation
of a Hispanic
Serving Institution--
you'll see Marla Franco
on a video later, who's
been elevated to a
associate vise provost
role for Hispanic initiatives.
And I think that shows
how important this
is to the institution.
We're only the third
AAU University.
And remember, there are
only 60 AAU universities
in the United States--
Harvard, Princeton, Yale,
Stanford, University
of Arizona.
We're the only third AAU to
achieve this designation.
It's a sense of great
pride for the university.
There was a lot of work
put into this over decades.
And it allows us to recruit
better students, better faculty
that are focused in the
areas of advancing our Latino
and Hispanic missions,
and it also opens us up
to new funding at
the federal level
that we didn't have
access to earlier.
Additionally, we have Rebecca
Tsosie that was at our table
this morning with Regent
Heiler and others,
and talking about the
incredible opportunity
for our Native
American students.
And I think that unlike
other states where
we have the largest
concentration
of Native American students
than any other state,
we have programs that
are already in place.
We've got we've got a
long and rich history
at the University of Arizona of
educating our native students.
But we must do better.
We need to go to
the tribal lands
and develop deep and meaningful
relationships and partnerships
to help them in their
K through 12 education.
And as I said before, even the
community college at the Tohono
O'odham Nation, to help
them to get students to us,
and provide programs, and
understand their needs so
that they can be successful
and either go back
to lead in their
tribes, or to go out
and be leaders across
all of society.
I think there's a great
opportunity for us
to have an annual
summit, probably
in this ballroom, where we bring
all 22 leaders of our Arizona
nations together.
And I would even say other
nations outside of Arizona
in the southwest.
It could be a
national conference
that could show our
leadership, and how
we have best
practices in educating
our native population.
So this next video, you're
going to see Rebecca talk
about our efforts around
inclusion and excellence.
Rob Williams, who's
on this video,
is one of the eminent and
probably the most accomplished
attorneys and law professors
on indigenous people law.
And I appreciate
them and Marla Franco
being part of this video.
These are very important
initiatives to the university.
These things make us
stronger and give us
a competitive advantage,
as I've said before.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Here at the
University of Arizona,
we're here to affirm
that diversity
is who we are as
a human community
and as a university community.
We love each of our students.
And I can't even
tell you how happy
it makes me to go into a group
and see students from here,
students from
around the country,
and students from around the
world who have chosen to study
at the University of Arizona.
One of the things that
HSIs across the nation
continue to ask themselves
is what does it mean to be
a Hispanic Serving Institution?
And one of the things that I'm
most proud about in the work
that we have just only begun
at the University of Arizona
is I'm proud to say that
we certainly are committed
towards putting the S HSI.
We are going to put serving in
Hispanic Serving Institution.
Having been here 30 years--
and actually, this is my
third strategic plan--
I have to admit,
this one's different.
The people that
we're working with.
The teams that have
been assembled.
The input that's been gathered.
Building support
among stakeholders.
Talking to tribes,
and excitement
in our communities
about this process,
about the possible outcomes.
This makes me very
optimistic, and very excited
to keep working on it.
[END PLAYBACK]
Another thing that permeates
across the entire plan
are the arts.
We're blessed-- I think
President Schaefer had
to leave.
He probably didn't
want to see what he
looked like in a younger age.
Oh, are you still there?
There you are.
Do you recognize that guy?
This is a young
President Schaefer.
As I said, he
started in his 30s.
And I've told him that
if he wants to come back,
I'll take a sabbatical, and
he can go back to the job.
But there he is with
his friend Ansel Adams.
And he was key of bringing
Ansel Adams' collection here,
and making the Center for
Creative Photography one
of the worldwide
international treasures
in the field of photography.
But we have a new
Dean, Andy Schulz.
I thought I saw
Andy here earlier.
And we're incredibly
lucky to have him.
And we're going to have him
be more than just the dean
of fine arts, but
the vise president
for fine arts across
the university,
emphasizing that the arts
needs to permeate everything
we do across the curriculum,
across the culture
of the university.
Of course, we've got
a great dance program.
You can see at the bottom
there I got to go to rehearsal.
They call it
practice in football,
but this was rehearsal.
And I told them--
don't take this the wrong
way, Coach Sumlin-- but I
said if our football players
executed as flawlessly
as those ballet
dancers, we would
be going to the Rose Bowl.
So we have a lot to learn
from our dance program.
But we need to invest.
We need to invest in the arts.
And we have aging
infrastructure.
Craig T Nelson was
here recently helping
us try to raise money to redo
Moroni Theater, our black box
theater.
And it's such an important
part of Tucson, our culture.
As I keep saying, this
place has a soul to it.
And part of it is
the creativity that
helps our students become better
at what they're going to do
as they go out in the world.
So I've included a picture of
the Mondavi Center at UC Davis,
and the Bing Center for
Performing Arts at Stanford.
These centers in
this district that we
need to invest in with a new
art museum, a new Fred Fox music
school--
these are facilities that need
to be invested in and updated.
And certainly, as part of this
plan, we're going to do that.
LARRY PENLEY:
President Robbins, when
you talk about the
HSI designation,
or you talk about the focus
on Native American issues
at the university, you
clearly are dealing
with leveraging place when it
gets to those particular groups
of students and faculty.
But in the arts, tell me how
you're going to leverage place
through the arts.
Well I think that certainly,
we've got to have facilities.
I don't know that
Jory and his wife
could have built the dance
program that they have here
without having great facilities.
Certainly you've got
to have great programs
to go in those facilities.
But I believe that these
performing arts centers--
we have, in my opinion, two
front porches or front doors
to the universities,
portals into the university,
with the community.
And that's through
athletics and the arts.
And I think that
it's a time when,
other than JP Jones, who
has his great seminar
series down in the Fox Theater,
and engages the community.
And certainly, Joaquin's
science lecture series
in Centennial Hall
packs the place.
But the community
doesn't really,
except in rare
occasions, come in
and go to English classes,
or physics classes,
or things like that.
But they get to come and
enjoy performances or games.
So I think having facilities
that people will come to,
that will attract students,
that will attract faculty
to build those programs
which do attract students,
is going to be really important.
So I'm not sure if that's
answering your question,
but it is one of our
portals and front porches
to the university.
I think we need to
invest in other areas.
Obviously in Tucson--
and this starts
to get into the
economic development
mission of the
University of Arizona
being the land grant
university for the state.
And what we are
tasked with in terms
of our stewardship of being
the land grant university.
And that's to build
out the tech parks that
started many years ago.
We've had this ground
between the airport
and the university
called the Bridges.
And I was reminded, as
I kept driving by there,
that this was a
bridge to nowhere.
But finally we're going
to move forward and start
breaking ground on the
bridges, and build out
what Bruce Wright and
others conceived as a plan
that I think will be
beneficial in that intersection
of fundamental discoveries
being translated
into commercializable products.
We're going to develop an
incubator at the old Walgreens
downtown that the
county has provided us
for a long term lease.
And we're building that out.
And Joaquin and Paulo are going
to have programs in there,
an incubator accelerator.
But we need to also build out
the Phoenix Biomedical Campus.
The board has charged
the EEC, which
are the three
presidents in addition
to John, to come together and
develop a plan for the Health
Sciences Center.
And I'll say a little
more about that later.
We also need to build out
our presence in Phoenix,
because the state
legislature is there.
It's the largest alumni base
of any of our alumni worldwide.
And I get up there as much
as I can, but I haven't
done as good a job of having
a presence in Phoenix,
and speak at public gatherings
there like President Crow gets
to do, because he lives close.
So we need to build out
our presence in Phoenix
more than we're doing.
And just like ASU,
for those of you
who've seen their beautiful
building in Washington DC,
right out the West Side
entrance into the White House.
We need a presence.
I've kind of
provocatively called
them embassy's at these
different locations.
It turns out that Duke does
call their DC office the Duke
embassy.
But this could be a
site for us to focus
a lot of the
important activities
around federal relations with
the agencies in particular.
It'll be a place
for our students
to go and do internships
and study abroad
programs that could be in DC.
We also have an incredible
Institute of Civil Discourse
that I think that most people
don't even realize we have.
But it's a phenomenal
program, and we certainly
need civil discourse
in this day and age.
I was reminded watching the
TV this morning, and it said,
the nation has been even more
divided than we are today,
but that resulted
in a civil war.
Do you have a question,
Regent Athena?
AUNDREA DEGRAVINA: I do.
Yes.
Thank you, Dr. Robbins.
Oh.
There we go.
I guess, with speaking
about all this expansion,
I was hoping maybe you
could also touch on,
what does the financing of
expansion for the university
look like?
As a part of this
discussion, how
do we make this
feasible with this
going to DC, going to
northern California, which
are all important?
How do we look at that from
a financial perspective?
Yeah.
We kind of covered that
with you guys yesterday,
but I'll expand on
what I said yesterday.
Obviously, there
are resources that
are available for strategic
investment currently.
And we're going to put
those things to work.
And parenthetically, there are
already things in this plan
that we're doing currently.
And there are things that we
will implement very soon that
will require no investment.
As I get to the fourth
pillar, actually,
some of our global
programs are making money.
Unheard of.
Our online program has
been developed, set out.
That's going to be
revenue positive,
because a lot of the upfront
investment has been made.
We're also going to look
at our budgetary process
and see if there are
some changes that
could be made that would free
up some of the money for more
strategic investment.
And then finally, we
think that if we execute
on these strategies, we'll win
more grants and more contracts,
and we'll grow our
student body, and we'll
have more students to be
able to have more tuition,
and do more things.
So that would be
sort of the outline
of how we would pay for this.
And the final thing, of
course, would be JP--
I don't know if
JP is still here,
but we talked about
it on the break.
We're going to have to get out.
We raised, as I said before,
over $300 million last year,
the largest amount in the
history of the university.
We've got to do almost $400
million a year for eight years
to hit our goal of
between $3 and $4 billion.
So as we were talking about
when Regent Ridenour asked JP,
how much money have
you raised today?
Just think about it.
Every day when
you wake up, we've
got to raise a million
dollars every day.
Every day.
And that'll be a big part
of funding this plan.
Make sure there's
a defibrillator--
AUNDREA DEGRAVINA:
No pressure, JP.
--if JP has a cardiac arrest.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
We had hoped to avoid
that funding question,
but it's good to
get it out there.
We can go into more detail
about exactly how we're
going to pay for it.
So back to our regularly
scheduled programming.
So I think there's
another opportunity for us
in the Presidio.
And why do I pick the Presidio?
President Crow picked LA, and
he moved from Santa Monica.
Now he's in downtown
LA, and he's
announced that he's in
town to compete on par
and to dominate USC,
UCLA, and Caltech.
I like that.
I have roots in
northern California
so we thought about northern
California and the Presidio,
because there's something
interesting going on there
that the World Economic
Forum, for the first time
in their nearly 50 year
history, has a branch campus.
Marc Benioff from Salesforce
has had a lot of influence,
I believe, in establishing
this campus there.
And it's an opportunity for
us to have a presence, much
like we would have
an embassy in DC,
to have one in Silicon Valley
in northern California.
So that we can help to expand
the tech transfer capabilities,
the companies that we spin
out, to have partnerships
with Silicon Valley
tech companies,
but also get capital
investment from venture
capitalists in that area.
And it puts us in the mix
of being able to have access
to the Pacific Rim,
China, India, Korea,
where we are going to
build micro campuses
and get students from.
So this would be our outreach.
And we think that
this will help us
in our quest for economic
development for the state,
but also help us to make
money for the university
so that we can
invest in this plan
and do the great things
that we want to do.
So when I got here,
President Crow
and I started talking about
what can we do together?
And we've had a series of
meetings that were primarily
led by George Post and Mike
Dake that are really focused
around biotech and
health sciences,
and what can we do together.
And there are many
things that we can do.
We already have partnerships
with NAU in the Phoenix
Biomedical Campus.
And as I said before,
the board has charged us,
all four of our
leaders, with coming up
with a plan for the
biomedical campus.
So I think we can be a
player in that arena.
But as I started to think
about this presentation,
and as I started
to think about what
we could do as a university and
my prior experiences in Texas--
by the way, I was actually
hired because 59 institutions
said we need someone to come
in and help organize us.
We want to work together.
We need a forcing
function to set up
research collaborations,
and innovation,
and economic development
type things we
could do as multiple
institutions together.
And it struck me.
I've got three examples here.
The top one is that TMC3.
Multi-institutional--
University of Texas,
Texas A&M, Rice,
Baylor, MD Anderson--
coming together to have a
meaningful, translational
research campus.
The one in the bottom
right is Research Triangle,
where University of North
Carolina, North Carolina State,
and Duke have come together--
years ago, decades ago now--
to build out an infrastructure.
And it really put their three
universities on the map.
And most recently, under the
investment of Mayor Bloomberg,
the development of
Roosevelt Island
in New York where Cornell
and the Technion have
come together.
I think we can do the same
thing at the Phoenix Biomedical
Campus.
But I, as we talked
yesterday, think
that it doesn't need to just
be health sciences and biotech.
I think we've got a
unique opportunity
with all of our
assets coming together
to be the world leader in the
business of space and space
exploration, in astronomy,
and in those domains.
A lot of it has
to do with having
the expertise to go into space.
But a lot of it also has to
do with technology development
and data management that will
help both health and our space
programs.
So I think this is a
big opportunity for us
to do something really big, and
to plant a flag in the ground
to say, we are going
to be the leaders.
Finally, the
governor, in dealing
with the Governor of
Sonora and the possibility
of having a launch site
for rockets like Vector
is producing.
The idea is that Vector is
producing these rockets that
can be fired inexpensively--
relatively inexpensively--
at the rate of one a day.
And so if you think about this
whole corridor from Arizona
through Sonora, I think we've
got a great opportunity there.
And the University
of Arizona is poised
and ready to work with the other
universities to develop this.
So that's the end of pillar 3.
More questions before
we go to global?
By my check, we have 50 minutes.
And I think we're
doing well here.
Questions?
Comments?
RON SHOOPMAN: I want to
once again acknowledge
this last slide.
In my view, one
of the real values
that this board with three
universities working together
bring to the state
is the opportunity
to take the talent
that exists not only
here, but at ASU and
NAU, and find ways
to put those talents together
to accomplish greater things
that we can do individually.
And I think that's an attitude,
and it's an intent to do that.
Let's leave the competition
for the athletics,
and let's work together in
ways that are good for Arizona
and the people of Arizona.
And I think we will
find that we're
successful beyond anything
we could do individually
if we can join forces
So I do believe that one of
the reasons we selected you
as a leader is that you took
59 different organizations that
wouldn't even talk
to each other and got
them to collaborate and do
wonderful things in Texas,
so we know it's possible.
And I think, as we discussed
yesterday, we're too small.
I mean, we're
three universities.
But I think we punch
way above our weight.
When it comes to assets like
space, both ASU and U of A
are true world
leaders in this area.
Just look at the awards
that are being given
from NASA and NSF and others.
And then on the health side,
we've got two medical schools.
We've got the partnership
that ASU has with Mayo.
We've got NAU with the
health sciences schools
that they have that
are located in Phoenix.
I just believe this is
an incredible opportunity
in both space and
health, and also
the health of space travel.
Because one of the tag lines,
our students go to Mars.
Literally and figuratively.
It's great.
I think we can get
people to Mars.
But can we get them back
safely and without cancer,
for instance?
So there are a lot of
opportunities here.
But the competition is not
up and down I-10 and 17.
The competition is in
Boston, and San Francisco,
and San Diego, and
Singapore, and London.
And there's no reason,
no reason in the world,
that we can't have
the right mentality
to think-- we don't need
to go to those places.
We can do it right here.
As a matter of fact,
they're going to come to us.
Especially around
the space sector,
I believe, because of all the
unique assets that we have.
Thank you.
What else?
Mr. Chairman, I
want to just take
advantage of the opportunity to
talk about the inflection point
that we are at.
We put the word
collaboration up there,
and we talk about it with
the other two universities.
But historically, this
is groundbreaking.
Having lived-- and I
said this yesterday,
and I and I'm repeating myself,
but it's worth repeating.
It wasn't that long ago
that the three universities
wouldn't talk to each other.
And I will tell you
that 30 years ago,
when I was in student government
at Arizona State University,
I was part of that problem.
[LAUGHTER]
I took my role as student
body president quite serious.
And at every
opportunity, would do
whatever I could to
compete with U of A
and try and come out on top.
But we have moved far
in the last 30 years.
And I think with Dr.
Robbins' leadership,
and his work with Dr. Crow and
Dr. Chang, is really historic.
And it is an inflection
point for our state.
I said yesterday
that our competition
isn't ASU, or NAU, or U of A.
It's the Research Triangle.
It's these other states
that have learned
long ago to work together.
That's our competition.
And we are stronger together.
And so for a
lifelong Arizonan, it
is very refreshing to see this.
And I think it bodes very,
very well for our future.
So thank you.
Absolutely.
Just a quick comment back
on Regent DeGravina's question
about financing.
I am just very impressed and
appreciative that Dr. Robbins
and the University
of Arizona has not
made this plan contingent on
investment from the state.
And in fact, have not really
talked about investment
from the state.
However I think the plan
does a great job articulating
the fantastic and
unbelievable benefits that
can come to the state
and to the universities
if the state was willing
to invest in this plan.
And I think gives us
a great opportunity
to go and articulate with the
legislature and the governor's
office the benefits of
the 50/50 funding model,
and how we would put those
additional resources to work,
should they become available.
RON SHOOPMAN: Thank
you, Director Arnold.
President Robbins?
ROBERT ROBBINS: OK.
Fourth pillar.
Sorry global and
international activities.
And I have to thank Brent
White for really converting me.
I'll talk about our micro
campuses here in a minute,
but these are our goals.
Currently, we really
haven't focused
on trying to procure
resources FROM
the World Bank, or the
Gates Foundation, or USAID.
Some of these
funding agencies that
fund big international
development or projects.
And so we have a
goal to, by 2025,
and I'm very confident
that we could
HIT this goal, to procure
new resources that would
help to pay for this plan.
And it's modest, in my
opinion. $10 million.
I think we can outperform that.
We want to be a top 10
national research university
for students studying abroad.
Right now, we have less
than 5% of our students.
We need to double that.
We think that we can be a big
performer in attracting more
students to the university.
International students,
currently single digits.
We need it into the
15% to 20% range.
And then finally, I'll talk
more about the micro campuses.
The micro campuses, as I said,
I was skeptical when I came in.
And after sticking with
it, and investigating,
and multiple hours
of discussions
with Brent, and Marc
Miller, and others.
A recent trip to one
of our newest partner
micro campus universities
in Lima, Peru.
People just came back excited
about the opportunities there.
And then their team
came here, and they
have a young, very aggressive,
visionary president.
And I thought, you
know, this is starting
to make a lot more sense to me.
And as we went through
and pressure-tested it
through this rigorous
planning process,
I think the micro
campus differentiates us
from any other
university in the world.
And the key is that our faculty
developed the curriculum.
Then we train their faculty
at our partner institutions
to deliver the curriculum.
And we give a joint degree.
And most importantly, we split
the tuition with them 50/50.
And so this is one
of the few things
in this plan that generates
resources to pay for itself.
And I think it's a really
remarkable, differentiating,
and competitive
advantage for us.
You can see a picture
of one of our buildings
there in Cambodia.
One of our universities.
And the one that's
been around the longest
is with Ocean
University, which is
one of the top
universities in China.
It gives us a ability
to deliver our brand out
to all these campuses
in the world.
It provides their students with
a US education and a degree.
It gives us the opportunity to
develop research collaborations
with these universities.
And as a launchpad, a natural
launchpad for our students,
as we try to grow our
study abroad programs.
We already have
infrastructure in place there.
And they're interesting
places, and stimulating places
that we have partnerships with.
Yes, Regent Manson?
LYNDEL MANSON: So this
generates revenue at this point.
So it's a profit
center, as it were.
What, outside of
generating revenues,
what do the numbers look
like in terms of our students
using these
facilities currently?
And what kind of
return, if any, do we
have of students coming
from the American
University of Phnom Penh, and
studying at U of A for a year?
And one of your
goals is to increase
the international
student population
at the U of A campus in Tucson.
Do those flow together?
Right.
Well that's the hope.
These are all very
nascent programs,
and others could answer those
questions more accurately
than me.
But I do know there are
a couple of examples
of law program with the
University of Hanoi,
which is one of
the top law schools
in the country of Vietnam.
That before we started
the program there,
we essentially got no students.
And I think over
the last few years,
we've gotten 10 law students
that have come from there.
The idea is that
students could complete
their undergraduate studies
at these micro campuses,
or even transfer
during their time,
or they could come here
from graduate school.
So I don't think the numbers
are really high right now.
And we only have
about 500 students.
One of the goals was to
beat 10,000 students.
We only have 526 students today.
So it's early on, and there are
only four operating campuses.
But I know Brent and
his team is out and hope
to develop 20 of these campuses
with the number of students
per campus that will get
us to 10,000 students.
And at that point, it
should be matured enough
that we'll see our students
going to these campuses.
But I think there have
been students who've
gone to Ocean as part of, if not
a complete semester of, study
abroad.
But at least go there
on a trip and understand
what the resources are that we
could develop a program there
eventually.
That's the hope, but
I don't think we've
gone very far with it today.
I'm under the
impression, maybe
mistakenly, that not
a lot of universities
are focusing on micro
campuses or partnerships
with other nations.
And I know there's a
lot going on in China.
Possibly India, Southeast Asia.
Do you plan to be in
the forefront of this?
And what is the planning?
I mean, what resources
are you going
to put to this immediately?
And where do you expect this--
I know you have the
statistics, but do we
need to make inroads in this
quicker than down the road,
since other universities
may well start getting
into this type of thing?
Because everyone's out for
the international student now.
Yeah.
I think this is
one of the things
that we highlighted
for you yesterday.
And I don't have
those numbers with me,
but I think we
left them with you.
This initiative calls for
about a million dollar,
million and a half dollar
investment in the next year,
which we're happy to do.
But Brent is out there.
I mean, you know, if he's
not global service on United
and whatever it is on
American, I would be shocked.
He's probably premier
status on multiple airlines,
because he's constantly
out there looking
for opportunities.
Now as to other
Institutions, of course
they've been at it
for a long time.
I mean, NYU does this very well.
You know if you go to NYU,
it's marketed very well,
there are 14 sites in the
world that you can go.
And it's a big part of
the experience there.
And others have tried it, too.
They've, in my opinion,
been the most successful.
But most places choose to invest
bricks and mortar, and programs
in their people on the ground.
And that just has not
been as successful.
And you've seen places
like Johns Hopkins
and Duke and Harvard
and Stanford retreat
from those models.
Sanford still has a
program in Beijing,
but not as big as the
idea that we had before.
And I think Brent
is on to something,
because you can do
multiple of these campuses
without a big investment.
And it's about
relationship building,
and getting the right fit for
their needs with the programs
that we have.
So we're on this.
He's very aggressively
going after this.
I think it's going to
be a minimal investment.
But we outlined that
this is one of the--
as we go through, and as
we talked to you yesterday
about the triage and
prioritization of projects--
this would be one of them.
And I think it's about
a million and a half,
$2 million investment that
we're eagerly putting that money
to work, because we think
the return on investment
is going to be good.
President Robbins, before
you go onto the next section
of this one, I apologize.
I'm just curious.
What are the implications
for your general education
and the changes to
general education?
That's one question.
If you could deal with that one.
I have a related one, though.
For the international program?
LARRY PENLEY: Yeah.
You talk about
your global goals,
and what you want out of the
students in this section.
So how does general
education change
as a consequence of this?
So I think it's a great
opportunity for our students.
We talk about wanting--
at one point, we said we
want 100% of our students
to have an international
experience.
I still believe that
that's embedded somewhere
in this plan, but I kind
of got push back on that.
And the fact is, we
could put them in a bus
and drive a few
hours south, and they
could do meaningful work along
the border and in Sonora,
and that counts.
And so I think that
that is a great part
of the general
education process.
There is a--
I don't have enough time
to put it all in here,
and some of these things
are a little controversial--
but there is a pilot project
that we continue to talk about
with Minerva to introduce
their curriculum
into our general education
projects, pilot projects,
for next fall.
Brent has looked at
Minerva's platform and said,
this is going to be
a great way for us
to deliver general
education across all
of our micro campuses.
So I think that
they fit together.
Obviously--
BOARD MEMBER: Bobby,
would you explain
Minerva for everyone benefit?
Ooph.
That's going to be a long--
the most successful
university in the world.
Minerva.
You want a tag line?
That's a tag line.
And so they've only been
around about four years,
and they have a very
aspirational goal
to change the way that
education is delivered.
We've been talking to
them now for about a year
about their offerings,
particularly
around the software
and platform that they
use to deliver their offering.
They only take 100
students a year.
And they have multiple
thousands of students applying.
And it's really an online
educational platform.
But the students start--
there are eight different
locations, I think.
And I'm not an expert on
giving the Minerva pitch here,
but I'm going to
do the best I can.
And I'll say you can
find them at www.
Whatever It is, Minerva.
Just Google.
But the idea is, they've
got an incredible software
platform and data analytics.
They film every
class, and they're
the ultimate in collaborative
and active learning
in the classroom.
And we just think
that that's going
to be a potentially
interesting pilot for us
to pilot in our general
education curriculum.
Above and beyond
that, Brent thinks
this is a great way for us
to disseminate our curriculum
around to our micro campuses.
A related question
though, President
Robbins, before you go on.
And by the way, it's
minerva.kgi.edu,
if you want the address.
But with regard to the
languages, you talk about 75%
of students being multilingual.
Now having studied both German,
Spanish actually, and French.
I'm probably only useful
in about one of those.
And it had to do
with the pedagogy.
So how are you going
to change the pedagogy
in languages taught here at
the University of Arizona?
Well I think--
I thought you were
going to ask me--
this is why I didn't want to
put this one on here, because it
says not measured today.
We don't know how many
students are multilingual.
The idea is--
LARRY PENLEY: Well, if
they're typical Americans,
they're monolingual.
But I recognize there's probably
more multilingual people
in the southwest than there are
in many parts of the country.
ROBERT ROBBINS: Correct.
And this is Duolingo for all.
I could pull it out and show
you how you can get multilingual
on your phone.
But the idea would be that you
would have a proficiency test
that you could give people.
The fact is that--
I'm forgetting now which
university it's a requirement.
That in order to
finish, you have
to be proficient
in two languages.
So the idea is that
because of our HSI status,
because of our desire to grow
and be an international leader
in students from
outside the US, we
think that this is something
that we can achieve.
The question is, how
do we measure it?
And that's always problematic.
I guess this one is maybe
not as metrically based
as it is spiritually
and aspirational based.
Regent Myers.
Just stepping aside
just one second,
I just wanted to
suggest, Mr. Chair.
You know, we had some discussion
on these micro campuses.
We talk about online
education opportunities.
The whole branding outside
of the United States.
And we know how
important our of students
are to the learning
experience for our students,
the opportunity for
residents students in Arizona
to go to other countries,
and the money that
comes here from other countries
to help support education.
I was going to
suggest, at some point,
this board should maybe look
at this a little bit more.
Because I don't know, in
my history on the board,
that we've really had
a discussion about what
out of country education
means to Arizona.
And I don't know
that ABOR should
be doing more advertising
for Arizona schools.
You know, there are just so
many open questions here.
But I think we all
recognize it's becoming,
and it's going to continue to
be, a more and more important
part of our overall student
body and our student experience.
So separate from this
U of A presentation,
I was going to suggest
that this board, maybe
in academic affairs, should take
this subject on at some point,
and have more of an intellectual
discussion about what
are all these platforms, and
how do they fit together,
and what is the opportunity?
Thank you, Regent Myers.
Thank you.
This just is a slide
to remind me to come back
to, we've just not
done a lot of work
in developing the procurement
of resources that help us
to go out and marshal our
resources around hydrology,
water expertise for arid
environments, engineering
prowess, public health, and
natural resources assets
that we have at the university.
To go out, and partner, and
help solve some of the world's
global challenges.
I think we do a really good
job, especially with water,
in terms of going
across the state,
partnering with the
native communities.
But also with the Middle East.
There are a lot of partnerships
Ben-Gurion University was here
recently signing a research
agreement, because they
live in a similar type
environment as we do.
So there are a lot
of opportunities.
And we really, until Brent
brought this forward,
and the group started
to think about what
we could do around
having global impact,
and procuring resources that
would pay for us to go and do
these type of research
partnerships and studies.
That this is how
important this is for us,
and made it into the plan.
As we get these students
on campus, right now,
we don't do as good
a job as we could
in terms of making
them feel welcome,
providing them with
the necessary resources
to retain them.
It turns out that our
international students are
retained at a fairly
high level, but we'll
have to increase that if we're
going to hit our 91% retention
goal.
And we make it
difficult. We make
it difficult for
all of our students
to have a joyful
existence as they navigate
through the university.
So the idea would be to
take the Park Street Union
and repurpose it and renovated
into an international center
for students so that they don't
have to run all over campus,
and many times, out into the
city miles away from campus,
when they may not have a car.
Most of them don't have a
car when they come here.
So the idea that we would
have different services
for passports.
I really like the idea that
every one of our students
needs to have a passport.
And if we had an
office there that made
it easy to go to
get that passport,
then I think more of our
students would have them.
You know, when our basketball
team went to Barcelona
last year, I think
probably 9 out of the 12
didn't have a passport.
So to process visas, to be
able to get their financial aid
and support from their
country of origin,
and to provide a cultural
center for events.
Watching World Cup soccer
games, for instance.
Or having food
services that could
be the best in the region.
Could be right here
in this center.
So we're pretty excited
about repurposing
this, and the modest
amount of resources
that we required to do that.
So that's the end of
our international story.
Excellent.
Thank you.
OK.
We're coming down
the homestretch here.
Pillar 5 talks about, how
can we run this university
in a more efficient manner?
Not only with
business operations,
but also with processes that
simply make everyone's job
easier to do every day.
I remember an encounter
with the deans
early on, where we were talking
about the need or lack thereof
of doing a strategic plan.
And many of them told me that
you don't need a strategic plan
to do x y, and z.
There are things that drive
us crazy every day that we
have to put up with, and you
don't need any strategies
for that.
You just need to change them.
So I said, OK.
Go home and write
down the 10 things
that make your job difficult
every day, and come back.
And we'll collate them, and
slice them and dice them,
and analyze them.
And many of the things
showed up in this plan.
And Jeff was kind enough
to take on the job
of going through and analyzing
many of these things.
But most of them make sense.
And most of them, such as, we
don't have a common platform
that ties us together.
So a new CRM system is
going to be very important,
and will be part of this plan.
We want to focus
on sustainability,
and we've got some plans to
outsource some of our utility
requirements that
would reduce our carbon
footprint and our
scope 2 emissions that
will cost us nothing, and
result in a 33% reduction.
And then finally,
require, make it where--
I think every student now
has to have a CAT card.
We would make it where
every student has
to have some digital
access to what we're
calling digital you, which would
be a platform that would help
everyone run through their
university experience
with a much more joyful
and purposeful experience.
I use the idea of, if we go
next door to the administration
building, there are a
bunch of seats out there.
And I kept asking for a picture
to put in this presentation.
I should have just
gone over there
and taken the picture
myself and put it in here.
But there an old
computer there that I
think people are lining up
to sign into this computer
so that they can get
financial aid, or access to.
And it shows you what a second
Industrial Revolution-type
operation we have going on.
And how that, by putting
us on one common platform,
that we would make people's
life easier every day.
And we could actually,
even though it
requires some upfront, sizable
investment, over the long term
it'll make us run
more efficiently,
make us more productive,
and cost less.
One other thing.
I just put this slide
in here to emphasize
that, at the start of every
strategic planning process,
usually you go through missions,
mission statements, vision
statements, and
develop core values.
And we chose not to
do that in this case,
because we felt we
had limited time.
And we thought--
this was already
adopted from the
last strategic plan,
and we thought these
were pretty good.
I don't think
anybody could argue
with any of these core
values or this mission.
But as we went
through the process,
we realized that they're
not commonly shared.
Most people don't
know about them.
If you're from ASU, you can
give the guiding principles
of the new American University.
And I'm not sure that
anybody can really
recite for you what are our core
values and purpose are here.
So as a postlude
to this process,
we're going to engage in
a process with the Purpose
Institute out of Austin, Texas,
and go from a grassroots level,
all stakeholder, alumni from
around the world, all students,
staff, faculty, and go through
this process of developing
a shared set of goals,
purposes, and values
that everybody would buy into,
and would know, and would
be part of who we
are in our true North
Star as a university.
So we're looking
forward to that.
As part of analyzing
our current culture,
I alluded to earlier an
organizational health
initiative and
survey that we did.
Send it out to 15,000 students,
employees, and faculty members.
And got about a
33% response rate.
And I talked about things
that we have strengths in,
in terms of talent and passion.
But the things that we
lack were role clarity,
a strategic vision for
the future, holding people
accountable, defining
what their jobs are,
giving them performance reviews
to either help them improve
or to reward them.
And that's one of
the things that we
haven't done as good a job of.
And I hope that if this
plan is successful,
we can find the money
to execute on the plan,
that we'll have
resources so that we
can give financial incentives
to our higher performers.
Because we haven't done as
good a job of that as we
probably could do, or should do.
And then finally, just having
more central organizational
leadership.
Or just the idea of not
having a common CRM.
It has implications on
business operations,
makes us more efficient.
Should help us with
saving some money.
But the other thing
it allows us to do
is to have better
cyber security.
And not have 250 different,
separate servers,
but have everybody
on the same platform.
So those are some
of the things that I
think will be not
as glamorous as some
of the other parts of the plan,
but certainly practical, helps
people live their daily
lives, and helps them
be more excited about coming
to work because they don't have
to fight all the red
tape and bureaucracy.
Of course, there's always
going to be some of that.
But we give this example here
about, we've already started.
And as part of this strategic
planning process, had this--
which seems to be small--
initiative, but we just couldn't
resist going ahead and getting
it going.
It used to take for
travel authorization,
if I said I have a meeting
at the NIH tomorrow,
and I need to leave tomorrow.
Well, I needed to start planning
that about a week in advance.
Obviously, you're
going to plan it.
But getting
authorization to even go
in the second
Industrial Revolution
that we were operating
in a year ago,
it would require about a
week of getting five or six
different signatures
on paper that
made its way around
the university,
and then you would
get your approval.
Now, today, I'm told that
we can just hit a button
and do it electronically.
Small example, but you
start to get the picture.
When we have this
infrastructure,
it can make us work
more successfully.
And then, this is
the digital you.
Think of this as
the Amazon offering
for students where they can get
access to their core selection,
manage their financial
aid, and other things that
will make their life
easier so that they
can spend more time studying
and improving their performance.
We think it'll help
with retention.
Certainly on financial aid.
If we can get it to them sooner.
The two main reasons that
we don't retain students
are mental health issues
and financial issues.
So if I have to wait three
months to get my financial aid,
then I'm at a high
risk of dropping out
because I have to get a job and
it delays me from graduation.
So we think that some of these
technological challenges,
if we're going to
be the land grant
university in the fourth
Industrial Revolution,
we've got to be able to practice
what we're espousing we're
going to give to our students
and to the outside world.
So we're almost at the end here.
One of the things
to get back to.
What are we going to do?
Is this the end of the process?
And I've said this now, I
think, three or four times.
It's the end of the beginning.
This is the structure
that we'll have.
We'll have a strategic
implementation group.
We have sent out
an advertisement
to hire someone
to run this plan,
to oversee the whole thing.
We'll have accountable
pillar owners for all five
of the pillars, and
then initiative owners.
And there will be weekly check
ins on each of the initiatives.
And this would be--
its not really intuitive,
but I wanted an example
that I could show you.
So these are the five pillars.
And each one of these blocks
represents an initiative.
And so we'll come back
to you, and show you.
If we show you that
there-- and we'll
do this on a quarterly basis.
Not only to report
to the regents,
but we'll have it
on our web site.
And we'll be very transparent
about which initiative
we're actually executing on,
and what the results are.
So you probably won't
hear a lot about the ones
that are in green.
But if they are some
issue, and they're
in the cautionary
yellow part, or if we
need to have a SWAT team go
in and help on an initiative
because it's just not
going, then this kind
of tracking system and reporting
system and metric system
will help us as we
go out and execute.
We've got to get the resources.
We've got A, B, and C tranches.
A is the one that
we're already doing.
We're already invested in.
B is the one that we've
committed to invest in.
C would be the ones that
we'll go and raise money
for and invest in.
As we go out and
inspire people to invest
in these programs, that'll help
us to be a better university,
and in many ways,
improve the world.
So we will report back
to you on several things.
One, the values and
purpose work that we're
going to do over the
next two or three months.
The update on where the Banner
Health Sciences strategic plan
is as it starts to roll out.
And I've mentioned RCM.
We'll come back and talk to
you about what our ideas are
about our budgetary
process, and what changes we
need to make to RCM.
I think there are going to be
some changes that are being
discussed by the task force.
And as I've said, I look
forward to hearing those.
The final thing on this
slide is, we obviously
have three important hires that
we're searching for right now.
All of these searches
are underway.
The provost, the CFO and
chief business officer,
and the senior vice president
for Research and Innovation.
And I think this plan
will be a good way for us
to engage candidates.
I think it'll be something
that will excite them.
It will give them
tangible evidence
about what this
university is about,
and where we see ourselves going
over the next 5, 10, 15 years.
And it'll be sort
of the litmus test
that we can use to
engage people about,
what do you think about
the direction of the plan?
Could you see yourself being
part of this leadership team
to help implement this plan?
So I think these hires
are going to be incredibly
important going forward.
And they're three of
the most important parts
of the university.
And over the next
six months, we'll
have these people in place.
So I've given you.
Now almost four hours of this.
And it's just a very small
part of the tens of thousands
of hours that we spent
putting this plan together.
So as we seek to raise Arizona,
to ascend our mountain peak,
to make the state of
Arizona the future state,
I'm drawn to these words by
our alum Alison Levine, who
I think is one of the first
and maybe only women to summit
all of the world's tallest
peaks and ski to the North
Pole and the South Pole.
While working at Goldman Sachs.
I don't know how
she did all that.
But I love this.
And we wanted to have
her here, but she's off
climbing some mountain.
But I love this quote.
"You don't have to be the best,
the fastest, strongest climber
to get to the top
of the mountain.
You just absolutely
have to be relentless
about putting one foot
in front of the other."
And that's what's going
to happen with this plan.
We will have to every
day, step by step,
do the hard work of
recruiting those students,
and getting them
here, and helping
them be successful, in
the long hours of writing
grants and winning those
grants to advance our research.
There's no magic bullet.
There's no magic formula.
There's just a lot of hard work.
And I think Allison
summarized it very well
So thank you for putting
up with my rambling
through and bumbling and
stumbling along here.
But I'm really very proud
to be the representative
to give you at least a
snapshot of the incredible work
that the people around
us have put together.
And I think this is a start
to a great roadmap for where
the university is going to
go over the next five 10,
15 years.
So thank you for your attention.
RON SHOOPMAN: Thank
you, President Robbins.
[APPLAUSE]
I'd like to offer the
opportunity to the regents
to make any comments
or ask any questions
at the end of the presentation.
Regent Krishna.
RAM KRISHNA: Thank
you, Mr. Chairman.
There'll be so many naysayers
from this group, I think.
Faculty especially.
We wanted to tell Dr. Robbins
that we are behind him
on everything he has said.
He has a great vision.
I want to support him
on this all the way.
Thank you, Regent Krishna.
RON SHOOPMAN: Thank
you, Regent Krishna.
Others.
LAUREN L'ECUYER: So
thank you Dr. Robbins,
for that presentation.
So I think personally,
being one of your students
now here at the U of
A, I'm proud to know
that this is the direction
that the university is headed.
I'm excited and inspired by
what you've presented here.
And I think the most
exciting part for me,
and maybe for Regent
DeGravina, too,
is that student success is
such a clear thread between all
of the pillars.
And it's something that
you drew attention to,
and something that is
really important to us,
and to your student body
and your student population.
And so I hope that you'll
continue that as you go forward
and implement each of
these things, which
I'm sure you will.
And specifically with the
general education conversation,
it's something that we've talked
a lot with the students about.
And they're super interested
in where general education is
going, and how they can
participate in that formation.
And so I hope that you'll call
on them as the real grassroots
kind of people to tell you
what general education means
to us as students, and how
it can be best utilized
in our education.
But overall, I'm really excited.
And I think the student success
part is vital and very clear.
And I think people will be
excited to see that this is
where the university is headed.
Thank you for those comments.
And as I keep saying,
the medical system
wasn't necessarily
designed for patients.
But the leading
institutions are now
formulating patient-centric
delivery of care.
And I think the same thing
about higher education.
We don't necessarily
have set this up
to be the most student-friendly,
or the most student-centric.
And it's an opportunity
in this point
in time for the
University of Arizona
to be a leader in this area.
So I appreciate
both of your inputs
in this planning process.
And all of our students,
particularly Natalynn,
our student body
president, and Marie,
our graduate and professional
student body president.
And others like
Anthony, and people
who've helped us and
sat in, particularly
on these general
education discussions.
It's been enlightening to me.
It's been invigorating.
And I think we're
to a place now where
we've got a common set of shared
values around learning outcomes
and skills, and things that we
need our students to achieve.
And I think it's going
to be exciting for them.
Instead of just picking
from 400 different courses,
and trying to find the
easiest A they can get,
and not having any themes or
any structure to go through.
I think this is going
to be a much better way
to impart general education.
And it's going to
help them, as I
said before, in any discipline
they choose to go into.
RON SHOOPMAN: Other regents?
Regent Penley.
LARRY PENLEY: Thank you
very much, Mr. Chairman.
President Robbins, I really
appreciate what you've done.
As we said earlier, all
of us have had a chance
to really be a part
of this along the way.
But I would just
say, I especially
appreciate the
plan's sensitivity
to the culture of the
University of Arizona.
As well, the challenge that it
presents to this institution.
Because it is both
sensitive to the culture,
but it presents the
institution with challenge.
I think you've done a
really outstanding job
of embedding this plan in
the place that we have today.
Arizona.
Tucson.
The southwest.
I think that's
admirable as well.
The engagement, as I already
indicated, that is so broad,
I think helps to move
this plan forward.
The fact that you've
established a roadmap, in a way,
for the future, and that
you've committed yourself
to persistence
and accountability
in the last slide or two
that you've presented.
But what I hope we'll also begin
to see, and I think we will,
is these sequential
imperatives that
are going to be so basic to
getting this plan implemented
along the way.
And the clarity with
which those imperatives,
those strategic imperatives,
have to be articulated.
That's going to be an
essential part, too.
And I look forward to that.
But I know you understand that.
But it's really a
great beginning.
And all of us who watched
you undertake this
knew it would not be easy.
We knew it would present you
with a lot of work ahead.
And I just laud what
you've done so far,
and look forward to
the future with you.
Thank you, Regent Penley, and
thank you for all your help.
Having been through this before,
along with President Schaefer
and President Lichens,
as I said before,
you've been of great help to me.
And we'll continue to have
good exchange of ideas.
And I know that you will
hold my feet to the fire.
And you know, I
get to run around
and see the incredible stories
of this university every day.
And so I simply steal their
slides and brag about them.
RON SHOOPMAN: Regent Heiler.
JAY HEILER: Thank
you, Mr. Chairman.
Dr. Robbins and Dr. Robbins'
team, thank you very much.
This was very interesting,
and engaging, and promising.
But I have to say
you probably had me
when you quoted the New
Radicals at the beginning
of the presentation.
[LAUGHTER]
And there's another
song on that same album,
which was the only album they
ever had that was any good.
And there were only
two songs they ever
had that were any good.
And the other one is called
"Someday We'll Know."
[LAUGHTER]
Equally pertinent
to the presentation.
And I'm glad that you put your
distinguished Wildcat alumnus
up here at the conclusion.
As you know, she makes her
way in life quite a bit
these days going around
and speaking to leadership
groups, groups of leaders.
And another quote
from her, which
I was able to quickly identify,
as I had heard it before
is that, "we tend to
think that progress
has to happen in one
particular direction,
but that's not the case.
Sometimes you're going to
have to go backwards for a bit
in order to get where you
eventually want to be."
Which she absorbed from
returning to the base camp
on ascent of Everest
before she got there.
And so finally, the other
point, she also made
in those same remarks is
that leaders must bear pain
with grace and vigor.
So I wish you the best in that.
[LAUGHTER]
ROBERT ROBBINS: I'm
bearing the pain.
I'm working on the
grave and vigor.
JAY HEILER: And you have
already demonstrated
that in your short time
as president at U of A,
as you have so many other
distinctive qualities
of leadership.
And so we're very
fortunate to have you here,
to have the team
you've assembled.
And we're very excited
about the future
of the University of Arizona.
We played Tears for
Fears at every meeting,
because the song "Everybody
Wants to Rule the World"
seemed applicable.
[LAUGHTER]
RON SHOOPMAN: Regent Myers.
RICK MEYERS: Dr.
Robbins, in the spirit
of the arts that you've
brought up a number of times,
just for you and the entire
team, I just want to say,
bravo.
ROBERT ROBBINS: Thank you.
RON SHOOPMAN: Anyone else?
Regent DeGravina?
AUNDREA DEGRAVINA:
Thank you, Mr. Chairman.
Something that I wanted
to save for the end
is, I'm really impressed with
how the strategic plan also
has not only the
student-centric focus, but also
the global approach
as we are entering
a more globalized world.
Every day, the
world is changing.
And the fact that the
University of Arizona
wants to stay on
top of that I think
is a key component to
this strategic plan.
And that's what's going to
keep higher education relevant
moving forward.
Thank you.
RON SHOOPMAN: So
President Robins, I
want to echo the comments of
everyone that has spoken here
today in their support for
you, and for the faculty
and students and everyone
in this community that
will need to get behind this.
So from the board,
I hope that you all
see this as a call to action.
This is not just a plan
that will sit on the shelf,
but rather, a plan that each
of you have to commit to.
Each of you have to be a part
of finding that path forward,
and doing what you can.
Providing the leadership at your
level that's necessary for it
to succeed.
As was said earlier,
this was really
an inflection point
for this university
and southern Arizona.
University of Arizona
under means everything
to Tucson and southern Arizona.
You have so much
influence on our future.
So we're counting on you
to do the things that
are necessary to make
this plan a reality.
I really liked pillar
5, because while it
isn't very exciting,
maybe, compared
to some of the other things, it
talks about your understanding
that the amount of resources
this is going to take
will require finding
efficiencies and effectiveness.
So as we execute,
we have to find
ways to do more in the most
efficient way possible.
That will resonate
with the legislature
and the governor, who hopefully
will fund part of this.
But it also resonates
with everybody who's
watching what happens here.
Being efficient and
effective and excellent
is a combination
that's hard to beat.
And I think we're on
the doorstep of that.
So I'm truly excited.
I congratulate you for
a job well done today.
And it is the beginning,
now, as we roll up
our sleeves to start the work.
So I'm going to save the final
comment to our esteemed--
ROBERT ROBBINS: Wildcat.
--Wildcat and previous chair.
So I do have to do
one bit of business.
I move that the board
accept the University
of Arizona's operational
and financial review.
Do I have a second?
Second.
I have a second.
All in favor, say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Your plan is approved.
Congratulations.
And now to our
immediate past chair.
Final comment.
Well, from this grateful
Wildcat, I only have two words.
Bear down.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
RON SHOOPMAN: We are adjourned!